Brother.
So, you really take shahada?
Don't be shy. If you say that makes
sense, it's clear. Then take shahada. I
have one question. Go on. Don't ask me
how old I am.
Another question they keep asking me
online.
Okay, that's my wife. She was a proper
Catholic background.
If If Allah is an everlasting Yeah. That
it cannot be Jesus because why? The
Christians never believed Jesus called
everlasting father.
Cuz remember the son will be born and
he'll be called everlasting father,
correct? So, that prophecy doesn't apply
to Jesus. Why?
Jesus' mother never called him
everlasting father.
Rather, if even as a Catholic, if you
believe
Jesus everlasting father is a heretic,
you're not Christian anymore.
So, that We have to understand, brother.
When you look at the Old Testament, you
can see there is a even the Jewish
rabbis will tell you you can see some
passages that are written
that there is, for example, Isaiah 42.
Isaiah 42 it speaks about prophets came
from Adam
from
um Kedar. Okay, if you go to Genesis
25:13, Kedar is a son of Ishmael. So,
but with that passage of prophecy,
there's some passages there
that is not correcting. I mean, they
would You can see they they said you can
you can see the scribes there were
different scribes. So, example, I'm
writing something, then you come to
adding to my writing. Then he comes to
adding to You can see that there's
different scribes, okay? So, that
prophecy cannot apply to Jesus. That
doesn't mean there's no prophecies about
Jesus in the Bible. We do believe there
is. Moses came with some prophecies
because we believe that Jesus it was the
true Messiah. No doubt about that.
However, the Romans, the pagan Romans,
they start glorifying Jesus and they
start making him God.
Remember the the Council of Nicaea, what
was it about? It's about establishing
that Jesus' nature is a God, son of God.
You see? And then remember who
passed on the ruling that he's God and a
man at the same time? It was the
Constantine. Constantine was a pagan.
Even there's a story saying he was not
even a believer in Jesus. He just
utilized Christianity to justify his
war.
And if you notice Paul cuz there's two
main figures that really corrupted
Christianity or Jesus' teaching. Paul,
what did What Paul said? He saw a
vision.
I saw Jesus.
Constantine, what he said? He said he
saw a vision that he saw the cross
behind the sun.
Yeah, Constantine. He said that. He said
he saw the The point here is that when
you look at Christianity and Judaism, it
doesn't make any sense. Doesn't mean we
reject everything. There's some truth in
it. As a Muslim, you have to accept
there's a truth in it. So, so that that
prophecy doesn't add up.
Like I said, no one ever called Jesus
everlasting father. His mother never
called him everlasting father. Rather,
whosoever says Jesus is everlasting
father, according to the Christians, the
Catholics, Protestants, this person must
be a heretic.
Make sense? Yeah. Alhamdulillah. So, if
Islam is clear to you, makes sense to
you, you know the shahada time?
So, you know it?
Shahada time which is the two terms, the
two testimony when someone becomes
Muslim. That there's no one worthy of
worship except Allah
and I bear witness Muhammad the
messenger of Allah and that Jesus is the
servant and the messenger of Allah.
That's how you become Muslim. Then you
start learning more and more.
You know? Alhamdulillah. So, if it makes
sense to you and it's clear to you, I
can tell you to say the shahada. You
repeat it after me. Alhamdulillah. If
you have any questions, I'm here to
answer it. If Islam makes sense cuz I
was speaking about Islam how Islam makes
sense, the prophecies that Prophet
Muhammad came with, Islamic legislation,
the Quran, all other things, you know?
So, if your your family are
Christian,
I mean, look, many times I mentioned
this story. My wife, her family chose to
be proper Christian.
Proper like practicing Christian.
But she said she said to me Christianity
doesn't make sense to her. She left it.
And she became Muslim when she was 14.
How old are you?
17. You're a big man, bro.
14 was 14, bro. She took that decision
even she was 14. She took that decision
because why? She said Christianity
doesn't make any sense. Especially
Catholic, you pray to Mary.
Then you pray to you They pray to to God
through Mary, correct?
Doesn't make any sense. Mary never
prayed to herself. She prayed to God.
Okay? So, alhamdulillah. If it makes
sense to you, it's clear to you.
Ashhadu an la ilaha illallah. Then you
repeat it in English.
All right? Say ashhadu Ashhadu an la
ilaha an la ilaha illa illa Allah Allah
wa ashhadu wa ashhadu an an Muhammadan
Muhammadan rasul rasul Allah Allah wa
ashhadu wa ashhadu an an Isa Isa abdu
abdu Allah Allah wa rasul wa rasul In
English, I bear witness I bear witness
there is nothing there is nothing worthy
of worship worthy of worship in truth in
truth except Allah except Allah and I
bear witness and I bear witness that
Muhammad that Muhammad is the last
messenger is the last messenger and the
servant of Allah and the servant of
Allah and that Jesus and that Jesus is
the servant is the servant and the
messenger of Allah. and the messenger of
Allah May Allah bless you, bro. Give you
a hug.
Mashallah, big man. Mashallah.
Mashallah, strong man. I'm bro, I'm
happy for you, man. Alhamdulillah. And
you know what? It's a blessing your
friends are Muslims.
That's a big blessing. Mashallah. They
can help you Allah, you know? And you
can alhamdulillah come to you You from
here?
Alhamdulillah. I mean, like how was your
family with you becoming Muslim?
Would they be okay?
I know it's going to be hard. You know
Nigerians, they're proper But
alhamdulillah, just be patient, be
respectful to them, be nice to them. But
you have to be strong. Earlier on I was
speaking about tests.
Allah will test us. Even me, Allah tests
me with my family, other things. Allah
will test us with everything. Stay
strong. Alhamdulillah. You from Nigeria?
No. Like Jamaica? Yes. Yeah, yeah.
Alhamdulillah. So, you have the brothers
here. They can help you, inshallah. Step
by step.
Okay, akhi? And
the the the the glad tidings I'm going
to give you, Prophet Muhammad
said
when a person becomes a Muslim all his
sins forgiven.
It's like a newborn.
Wallahi, it's a blessing, brother. How
many young people out there they're just
walking cluelessly, they don't know what
they're doing. Alhamdulillah, Allah has
chosen you to accept Islam. Jesus was
not a Christian. Jesus submitted himself
to God. You understand? Christianity
Like Jesus never called his followers
Christians. The one that called them is
Paul.
So, Jesus had no clue about the name
Christianity.
You understand? So, when we look to
Moses, same thing. Because what is
When we say Jesus, Moses, Abraham, Noah,
Jacob, Daniel, Isaiah, Isaiah
Jeremiah, they were the Muslims. What
does that mean? Doesn't mean they were
speaking Arabic or they were from the
Arab peninsula. It means they submit
themselves to God according to God's
teaching.
That's what it means.
Like Moses never said I'm a Jew. Even
Judaism is not in the Bible the Bible
Old Testament. So, alhamdulillah, I'm
very happy for you, brother. Stay
strong, inshallah, because Allah will
test you. This life is full of test. But
when you stay strong, alhamdulillah, you
know, learn. You have to learn.
Alhamdulillah, study. And step by step.
Alhamdulillah. Like you know, what you
have to understand, brother, is what?
We come to the Bible, correct? The Bible
we we have in English.
The Bible in English is being translated
from Greek.
But guess what? Jesus never spoke Greek.
Jesus spoke Aramaic or Syriac, yes?
So, the translators of the Bible, do we
know them? We don't know them.
If we don't know people, can we trust
them?
You cannot trust them. So, why would you
trust in this Bible is being translated
from one language to different language?
We don't even know the translators.
But when it comes to Quran, Quran is we
have it in its pure language, Arabic
language.
That's why it's not allowed to recite
Quran in the prayer in English. You have
to keep it in the Arabic language.
That's why it's being preserved. Also,
one of the miracles of the Quran You
from Nigeria, brother? One of our Imam
is Nigerian. He He memorized the whole
Quran.
Word for word, letter for letter. The
most You know, I always mention this
challenge here. If all the Muslims and
the Jewish and the Christians, all of
them decide to burn their scriptures,
say we should have nothing with us.
The only book will be with remain with
us is the Quran because it's our hearts.
Every If even if we want to bring it
back into the written form
the Muslim children can do it. The
Muslim scholars can do it, no doubt. But
even the Muslim children memorize the
Quran word for word, letter for letter.
You know, everyone memorizes the
alphabets.
But I can get a pen and write A
O, yeah? My mom said, "No, no, no. You
made a mistake. It's ABC." You see? So,
because everyone memorized it, it's hard
for me to corrupt it.
That's why the Quran, subhanallah.
So, the Quran since the time of Prophet
Muhammad,
there were people who scholars of Quran.
Their job to sit down in the mosque
and teach the Quran for 30 years, 40
years, 50 years. Their job is just to
teach the Quran.
We have alhamdulillah in our mosque we
have four people that memorize the Quran
word for word, letter for letter.
You don't see that with the Bible.
The Bible
I I've spoken to rabbis, priests. They
haven't even memorized one chapter.
Me, I memorized the Bible better than
them.
I can tell you about some passages word
for word, letter for letter.
See, the Muslims, they memorize the
Quran. We memorize Sunnah.
Alhamdulillah. And Allah mentioned in
the Quran
we have made Quran easy to be memorized.
That's why you go to Africa, Asia,
Europe, Britain, America
uh Caribbean, Muslim children memorize
the Quran word for word, letter for
letter. Sometimes they don't even speak
the language of the Quran.
But when they read the Quran, they read
it perfectly. The example, I'm not sure
if you had my analogy. Imagine all of us
here we don't speak Chinese.
But we memorized the book in Chinese.
They're thinking, "What? How How you
memorize a book thick like this in
Chinese and you don't speak thick like
this in Chinese and you don't speak
Chinese?" Subhanallah, this is the
miracle of the Quran. But,
congratulations. May Allah bless you, my
brother. My young brother,
alhamdulillah.